here to talk about the u.s as
courtesy of usaa talking about the army
navy game that his brother played in
um and chris brockman you know this is
going to get me some daddy points at
home because you know we watch yankee
baseball all the time of course
uh the man who led the major leagues in
home runs this past season
first baseman of the new york yankees
here to talk some football is luke
voight how are you luke
yeah i didn't know you're a yankees fan
oh luke wow look
born in brooklyn raised in staten island
i fell in love with the new york yankees
and i'm going to date myself because i
know you're you're a youngster luke
you're 29.
um i i fell in love with the new york
yankees when chris chambliss hit a home
run in 1976
to make the world series and i have been
a die hard ever since
oh yeah yeah and as you know luke i i
don't know if you if you've
been watching my career at all uh as a
broadcaster i am a savage in
in my version of the box so that's me
yeah you might have had me in the 40
yard dash too oh i don't know about that
luke
i don't know about that i don't i know
you don't steal a lot of bases uh
but uh you start you saw me hobbling
around the base pads this year man i
couldn't
i couldn't beat a turtle this year well
you certainly well it doesn't matter i
guess when you put it over the fence you
put it over the wall
um before we get into a little bit of uh
of everything going on
uh how have you been handling your
success luke i mean your life has
certainly
uh taken an uptick in in terms of uh
recognizability and also success
what what has this been like for you the
last couple of years
uh it's been awesome man it's uh it's
been a blessing for sure um
you know i never thought i was gonna get
traded when i was in the moderate to st
louis and
um you know i took it and ran with it
man but you know my life hasn't changed
man i'm
i'm just a midwest boy you know i'm uh i
just moved down to
florida so i'm trying to get better at
golf um
and do a little bit of fishing so life
lively man i can't complain
so and you grew up um if i'm not missing
a midwest in
in missouri and now here you were
playing for the st louis cardinals and
you got traded was that something that
uh
depressed you disappointed you shocked
you how would you term that even though
you were going to the new york yankees
well i mean i would say you know saint
louis is probably you know
you know the elephant championship so
that includes the second best team and
you know obviously i get to play for the
yankees with the
with the most championships and all
sports so um a little different
obviously the fans are a lot different
um everybody says i'm the first yankee
fan that looks like a yankees baseball
player or whatever something like that
but um
it's uh it's been awesome and um
you know playing in the bronx getting
the luke chance you know it's a jungle
man
but you know the midwest everybody loves
you you know they uh you come in from a
different team whether you're the cubs
or the you know reds
you know the cardinals will uh show up
some support for you but you know they
both pack the houses and um
it's pretty cool to get to play for your
hometown team but then you know get
traded to
you know to the yankees you get to wear
the pinstripes which a lot of
you know a lot of unbelievable baseball
players have you know played forever for
so
well you got the perfect first name if
you're if you're hearing any blue birds
right luke
you got the perfect first name exactly
that's you know i
when i first got up i you know i i
sucked and you know it still sounded
like people
uh were luking me so of course that's a
perfect way to do it and
uh what was it like however this year of
playing with no fans in the stands
though
i mean i cannot imagine how that must
how weird that must have been to start
things out
certainly you know uh you've been
playing in front of
even when you're playing pony ball maybe
in front of your
your family what was that like for you
luke
um you know i played a small school you
know missouri called missouri state so
it was like playing
you know at missouri state but we didn't
get a lot of fans
but um you know it's a lot different man
you know obviously new york's a
different place right now you can't
enjoy the city
you know you can't go out to dinner you
know on the road you're pretty much
locked down in our hotels
um you know um we played in buffalo
which is different playing at a triple
a stadium you know it's uh it was a
grind man but you know 2020 has been a
grind for everybody and you know we
fought our way through it and
you know fell short you know on the
ultimate goal of winning number 28 but
um it was different man we miss the fans
you know they make baseball what it is
and
you know hopefully uh you know with
spring training right around the corner
we can get things rolling up
you know rolling back to normal luke
voight here on the rich eisen show new
york yankees first baseman the man who
led of major leagues and
home runs right here on the rich eisen
show okay so you're you're talking about
the army navy game because your
your brother played in this right this
is your military connection first i
gotta say go arm and beat navy
you know obviously this game's an
unbelievable game but um
you know i've got to go to a bunch of
these and it's you know my favorite
sporting event i don't know if you guys
have but it's it's going to beat
everything
you know usually the fans are more
compassionate you know it's a
win or go home game the boys always show
up regardless of records
um it's just overall fun experience you
know with the
with the cadets and the midshipmen
marching in and then the flyovers and
you know the whole week and leading up
to it so you usually get the boxing
matches on you know that thursday or
friday so it's a
it's all around awesome weekend but yeah
i partnered with usaa
to you know help this army navy game and
you know help fans
if you look at you know both my
instagram and twitter you can see that i
posted you know a picture of me my
brother and my wife
you know at the stadium you know where
you know we're used to all going to and
uh
you know this year uh if you visit
armynavyhouse.com
um there'll be uh two winners from each
side you know those members receive
airfare and uh hotel and game tickets to
next year's game which will be in the
city which will be awesome
and then another thousand will get uh
commemorative tickets so it'll be a fun
little competition so you can put out
the best picture but um
it's a way to get the fan involved since
they can't be at the games this year
yeah upload a photo that shows off your
fandom of army or navy
um and your favorite uh army navy game
memory you're entered for a chance
uh to win and it's a trip as you said
including flight hotel and game tickets
to the army navy game in 2021 that's
going to be in the city as you mentioned
the great city of new york and
again just to make sure everyone
understands certainly navy fans or luke
voigt fans or yankee fans
uh you were rooting for army because
your brother john is a west point
graduate and played
for army from 2014 to 2017. let's just
make sure everyone understands that
right luke
yeah so yeah you know my brother was uh
the captain and
um for army for there he was there for
five years one year at the prep in all
four years at west point
and then uh yeah graduated a couple
years ago and you know he's the reason i
wear number 59 now
after uh garrett took my number so uh i
went
a lot of passion and i probably have a
reason to you know pick a number out you
know with my brother wearing
a 59 cells hold on a second luke voight
hold on a second
when you say garrett took your number
you mean you didn't take
any garrett cold dollars from him
for that right he didn't give you
anything he just took it
luke i don't know about oh i guess i
worried that wrong but
i don't know maybe i got a little
something but okay i'd love to share
that oh no no i just want to make sure i
mean because
he has all the steinbrenner dollars well
the ones that
stanton doesn't have he has all of them
so i just want to make sure you did
you you were you you were able to wet
your beak a little bit with something
right luke so yeah i mean at least he
could have bought me a house or a paper
or something
yeah because if i'm not mistaken at
least i saw on your instagram feed
you're expecting
correct you and your wife were expecting
luke yeah it's our first kid so uh
super exciting um just past first
trimester so it's uh
it's scary but you know i'm super
excited this is great
and 59 i guess is your brother's uniform
number when he played
for army yes sir yeah so uh
we're in that family keeping on the
family so it's up
it was a unique number i didn't know i
had no idea what number i was gonna have
and you know
i got my brother's jersey you know
framed up on my wall in my man cave and
you know my wife was like why don't you
be number 59 i'm like
how the hell did i not think of that i
mean i don't know
all the other yankee numbers are
freaking taken cause they're on the hall
[Laughter]
i know because they've all been retired
hey maybe 59 can go
would look great out there in monument
park one day luke you know what i mean i
gotta hit i gotta hit a
crash on more home runs there brother
absolutely so uh
how you know obviously you're you're
you're a man of stout size
standing next to aaron judge luke is
that a tough is that a tough two shot
for you
or what is he taller how much taller is
he
than you 86 you know
i'm like 60. that's it huh that's a
tough two shot in it
i mean between him and stan they both
could play tight in the nfl they're like
they're like like two jimmy grahams
[Laughter]
so that's how tough a two-shot it is um
do you have a favorite nfl team
luke yeah i heard you guys talking about
uh
michigan ohio state thing man yeah i'm a
huge football fan
i like i got like three tvs in my
basement dude that's all i do is watch
football
okay so what's your what's your team
who's your team
well i'm from st louis so the rams you
know broke my heart
leaving you know stan you know up and
left again
um so i moved down to tampa so i'm
hopping on the on the brady bandwagon
even though brady broke my heart about
uh what 19 years ago when they beat the
rams
so is there a yankee fantasy football
league
is there something going on there yeah i
i finished in eighth dude i uh
i drafted michael thomas because i had
the eighth pick
and seven running backs went all in
front of him and i was hoping i'd get
david cook at seven
he got taken by britain i think and then
i had to take michael thomas and that
has been the worst pick of all time in
the first round this year so um
i got screwed it's a tough one okay so
who's winning the
the yankees uh fantasy football league
right now
um i i know
let's see i think dj's in britain's in
uh harkey's one of our coaches i think
he's in first place
okay um i think hicks
i don't remember the other two because i
i i lost the other night when uh beyonce
john i
had a chance to get to 60 and deontay
johnson decided to score another
touchdown so and had like six catches so
i got screwed so it's a pr league the
new york yankees fantasy football league
is a ppr
league luke so what you're saying yeah
but you only get half points
only it's a half point very good all
right and uh when you say
dj's in are you talking about 20 21 or
what are we talking about where do we go
hopefully 20
[Laughter]
how good is that guy as a baseball
player huh how good is that guy
dj lemayo rancher is the reason we call
him the machine then
and uh it's it's he's the best hitter
i've ever
you know seen live it's ridiculous what
do you mean
i was thinking all around hitter hit it
all over the place double singles you
know i've said this in interviews before
but i think he's the only guy in the big
leagues that doesn't get shifted
because he hits the ball everywhere
that's a good that's a
i mean that's why you are who you are
that's an excellent point he is a
machine
he has just been dynamite it's just been
so much fun to watch him and i hope they
he gets to stick around and then okay a
scale of one to ten
how much of a red ass is brett gardner
luke scale of one to ten
frank gardner's the best man he's the
best
but uh you guys saw it even more last
year when he when he slammed his helmet
and
it hit him in the face and then he's
pounding the top of the top of the
dugout so uh
yeah he's the best man he's the he's
he's the entertainer at baseball on
these it's great man
he's the best so that's also it's 11 in
terms of being a red ass one to ten it's
11
for brett gardner yeah okay yeah very
good or 59 do you guys just keep this as
a as a
something for us to uh to have is this
sponsored by number 15 on the the
uniform
that luke's brother john wore when he
was in the army navy game
and you should watch the army navy game
on cbs at 3 eastern time
and go to armynavyhouse.com with a photo
of you showing off your fandom of army
or navy with your favorite
favorite army navy game memory and you
can win a chance to go to the 2021 game
in new york city
luke thanks for uh everything that
you're doing as a yankee and for for
helping promote uh a great sporting
event and let's uh let's do this down
the line
i will be more than happy to help you uh
in your fantasy
draft next year as a thank you all right
yeah maybe we'll facetime here
you can have a little bit of fun but
yeah hey uh at the end of the day go
army
uh beat navy there you go thanks for the
call that's luke voight of the new york
yankees
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here